[Music]
mattie Patti yes papa writing theories
yes Papa telling lies no papa
[Music]
this taste is the taste of a liar
Matty patty
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where even
Speedwagon is afraid of today's episode
because today we're covering JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure now in case you're not
familiar with Jojo it's a classic shown
in battle series in the vein of Dragon
Ball Z and my hero academia except well
it's a bit more bizarre just saying a
lot since my hero has a guy who shoots
tape out of his elbows and Dragon Ball
stars gorilla people from space anyway
to give you just the smallest taste of
what this series is all about the first
main arc starts in the Victorian era
where we follow Jonathan Joestar a rich
British martial artist who uses rhythmic
breathing to channel the energy
signature of the Sun into his fists so
he can explode punch vampires vampires
mind you who can flash freeze anything
they touch just by dropping their own
body temperature because you know
vampires can do that in this world by
part three of the series it's almost a
totally different show about people
using psychic projections cold stands to
beat the tar out of other psychics
sometimes psychic babies psychic animals
- because it's anime on the manga side
Jojo is one of the most successful
series in history with over a hundred
million copies in print and it's
starting to really take off in the u.s.
not only because it's just - really fun
off-the-wall show but because it is a
walking meme
[Music]
yes you saw that scene right it's a man
freezing time to drop a steamroller onto
his opponent but oh no friends that's
not just any man no deal now for as much
as I'd love to analyse how no one is
able to deflect the emerald splash
because seriously no one has ever been
able to do it no one are you sure about
that today I have my sights set on a
different moment you see each part of JJ
be a stars a new cast of characters and
today I want to cover a meme from its
most recent anime season covering one of
the best arcs that the show has seen so
far golden wind where the jojo story
moves away from vampires in Victorian
England and instead moves to Italy to
fight against some mob bosses to set the
stage we meet Giorno Giovanna a petty
crook who's living in Italy and has hair
that looks like a plate of pasta
specifically manicotti when he
accidentally kills a gangster named
leaky eye Luca who's leaning on him for
some protection money
our hero ends up over his head riding
the trolley later that day he's
confronted by Bruno a mafia lieutenant
in charge of investigating Lucas death
Bruno here has two pretty impressive
abilities first he can create zippers on
any surface in order to travel through
space and tear objects apart oh yeah and
secondly and more importantly for our
purposes today he has a remarkable sense
of taste that might not seem as
impressive as interdimensional zippers
but just wait it leads us to one of the
show's most enduring memes he claims to
be able to tell whether or not Giordano
is lying simply by licking his sweat and
in that one moment the internet lost its
collective minds licking politicians
licking animals licking cake since we
all know the cake is a lie licking
Nintendo's switch cartridges anything
that Bruno could lick was licked all of
it to see who or what was lying to us
and all that got me thinking is Bruno's
power possible is it possible to tell
whether someone is lying simply by the
flavor of their sweat and if so what
does a liar taste like strap-in
theorists because it's all on today's
episode of Mad Pat's bizarre Theory
dancer
those questions we first need to figure
out what happens to our bodies when we
lie lying actually takes a lot more
effort than telling the truth when you
lie you're not just recalling something
that really happened to you you're
remembering that information you're then
concocting a believable alternative to
it and then you're making a conscious
effort to sell that you're telling the
truth concocting tracking and sustaining
lies puts a lot of pressure on people
and generally speaking that pressure
results in stress now when you
experience stress your brain releases
three hormones adrenaline cortisol and
norepinephrine which collectively cause
various changes to happen in your body
your heartbeat accelerates your focus
increases your reflexes sharpen all of
it is to help you deal with whatever
threat you might be dealing with in the
moment and yes you are also gonna sweat
here but it's not sweat in the same way
that you do when it's hot or when you're
exerting yourself that spike of
adrenaline actually activates special
sweat glands your apocrine glands which
produce a special kind of sweat a sweat
that actually gets you to smell
noticeably worse than your regular sweat
and so it would only make sense that
sweat with a different smell would also
come with a different taste right well
it's quite that simple unlike the normal
sweat produced by your eccrine glands
which is made up mostly of water and
salt
this apocrine sweat is a milky looking
substance that's made up of proteins
cholesterol and fat all of which are
food for the bacteria on your skin it's
the bacteria on your skin consuming and
digesting that sweat which causes it to
smell bad the sweat itself though is
actually odorless and if you were to
lick it up right when someone started to
sweat it out you wouldn't actually taste
anything at all so now Bruno wouldn't
taste anything particular in the sweat
produced by giorno as he's lying but he
would be able to notice the absence of
normal sweats salty flavor of course
this scene is also taking place on a
balmy Italian summer's day right after
giorno climbed ahold dang building so
unless those cable cars have amazing
air-conditioning chances are that
hormone sweat would be mixed in with a
lot of regular old sweat and it'd
probably be hard to tell the difference
but even then that diluted sweat mixture
would be slightly less salty and with a
good enough
of taste Bruna would indeed probably be
able to tell the difference hauling out
Giorno correctly as the liar that he is
that said there is another problem here
the apocrine glands are mainly
concentrated in the armpits and in the
genital region and Jojo for whatever
this show is is not that sort of anime
so Bruno isn't exactly licking the right
spots if you get what I mean
to get himself the best results now
there are some apocrine glands that are
located on the face specifically on your
eyelids and the wings of your nostrils
so some apocrine sweat might have made
its way onto journos cheek and if bruno
really does have super sensitive
tastebuds he could theoretically pick up
on that so well the show may be bizarre
the science at least in this ridiculous
scenario actually holds up you can in
fact taste a liar the taste of a liar as
it turns out is salty but not too salty
just like the perfect french fry so case
closed
myth confirmed we can all go home now
right wrong because well the sweat the
body produces while lying is different
from the sweat produced in response to
heat and exercise it's identical to the
sweat produced under literally any kind
of stress so you'd find that same flavor
on someone who's running late to an
appointment or waiting on potentially
bad news from a doctor or who's worried
about an upcoming exam or just pick a
random example here someone who's
confronted with questions about a dead
body by a violent mobster that is going
to be stressful regardless of whether
you're the killer or not so yeah
Bruno's lie-detector test is gonna be
extremely vulnerable to false positives
he's going to be wrong a high percentage
of the time which seems like it should
be a big deal when he's deciding whether
or not to kill you in retribution for
your crimes but false positives happen
all the time in real world lie detection
too so Bruno's in good company in real
life may not be licking people during
interrogations to see if they're lying
but we are doing something that's pretty
darn similar you see the polygraph test
orb lie detector test works on similar
properties to Bruno's taste test
well they don't measure the composition
of
sweat they do measure factors like the
amount of sweat blood pressure pulse
breathing all to determine whether or
not a subject is aroused when answering
the questions not that sort of arousal
row up in essence the polygraph test
looks for signs of stress in an examinee
in order to determine whether they're
stressed when answering questions which
in turn could lead to the conclusion
that they're lying and in order to
mitigate the possibility that sources of
stress other than lying will mess with
the results they're actually strict
procedures that must be followed in
administering these sorts of exams
requiring that the exam happened in
environments free from distraction and
at times when the examinee isn't gonna
be feeling excessive levels of emotion
and even then even when all of those
factors are at play still polygraphs
according to the most favorable reports
are right maybe like 85 percent of the
time but don't get too excited
some say the accuracy is actually a
whole lot lower according to polygraph
critic David liken holograph tests have
a 65% chance of actually catching a liar
which is uh not a great accuracy rate
that is a low D on your report card the
National Research Council found no
evidence of the polygraphs validity and
according to the Journal of forensic
psychology practice two thirds of the
scientific community with the necessary
experience to evaluate polygraph results
actually considered the whole thing to
be a glorified pseudoscience so here we
have Bruno licking faces once again
running his interrogation on a noisy
crowded trolley that doesn't exactly
meet the requirements for a sterile
distraction-free testing environment and
while some might disagree I would argue
that giorno suddenly finding a
dismembered human eyeball in his hand
would qualify as an emotionally charged
event that might prompt some stressful
sweating again increasing the chance for
a false positive even more long story
short here runo is working with fewer
data points and is significantly biasing
his own results with bad testing
methodology the real question we should
be asking here is it what does a liar
taste like it's more like how many
innocent people has Bruno zipped in half
as a result of bad interrogation
techniques and shaky science sup one do
me a favor and drop a steam roll
from that guy's head but hey that's just
a theory ah film theory cannot do that